Redheads aren't going extinct.
They aren't soulless-- well,
any more than anyone else is,
scientifically
speaking-- and they've
been around for a long time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, gingers and others!
Trace here from DNews to
settle some old scores
about those redheaded
people among us.
Now before I dive
in, you can probably
tell I am not a redhead.
Although when I let
my beard grow out,
I do get little red hairs, so
I don't know what that means.
Anyway, redheads
get a lot of flack,
so we explored some of the
science behind their freckles.
Redheads have been in
literature for a while.
The Oxford English Dictionary
says the term "redhead" first
appeared in 1510
and it's associated
with a fair complexion and
Auburn or ginger colored hair.
But the gene mutation
that causes redheadedness
has been around much longer.
It came about 50,000 years ago
when humans moved from Africa
into the cloudier
climbs of Europe.
The redheaded human is a
result of a gene mutation
on the MC1R gene, which is
responsible for controlling
melanin production,
probably not a surprise.
Melanin is what gives skin,
eyes, and hair their color.
Blonds are also a result of
the change in the MC1R gene.
New research published
in the journal
Molecular Biology and Evolution
discovered another mutation
that causes fairer
skin complexion.
Scientists discovered
it while analyzing
the DNA of 1,000
people from Spain
and figure it's
our body's response
to lower vitamin D production
from the lessened sun
outside of Africa.
Sadly, the mutation
goes hand in hand
with lessened protection
from UV rays as well.
Darker skin reflect the rays
better than lighter, so fair
skin has a higher risk for
melanoma, or skin cancer.
When lab rats with comparable
pigmentation were tested,
50% developed melanoma
before they were even
exposed to the UV light!
So get out there and
get tested redheads.
So while some of those sayings
about redheads are true,
rumors of redhead extinction?
Grossly exaggerated.
In 2005, the internet was abuzz
with a source at the Oxford
Hair Foundation claiming
the recessive gene was
disappearing.
In reality 80% of humanity
carry the recessive gene
underneath their
own dominate one.
It's important to note that
the gene is double recessive.
So both parents must
carry it to birth
their own little gingersnap.
And in total, 2% to 6% of humans
in the Northern Hemisphere
and only 1% to 2%
worldwide are gingers.
This rare gene mutation
has been rumored
to affect other
redhead traits as well.
For example, pain reception.
Even the MythBusters
explored this phenomenon.
Anesthesiologists
know that redheads
do need more of the
lidocaine anesthetic
before surgery, about 20%
more than dark haired people,
in fact.
However, when it comes
to opiate painkillers,
they actually need less.
This has to do with pain
receptors being triggered
differently in people
with MCR1 mutations.
Did you have misconceptions
about redheads before?
Be honest, everybody.
Share your thoughts with
us on our Facebook page.
And thanks for
watching DNews today.
We air twice daily,
seven days a week.
So if you like
what you're seeing,
save testtube.com/dnews as a
favorite so you don't miss any.
It's easy.
Thanks again.
{MUSIC PLAYING]